-You're on the Senate
Intelligence Committee.
And so I want to talk abou
the news this week.
And it really was big news
-Yeah.
-And if there is ever a time t
celebrate the death of anyone,
someone like al-Baghdadi
would be that.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Can you talk about
both the importance of tha
and how there was value to that?
And also the handling of i
from this administration?
-Well, first of all, I want to
just praise our special forces
the American intelligence
community.
You know, I work closely wit
them in connection
with my service on the Senat
Intelligence Committee.
And they tirelessly and
selflessly do incredible work.
And they never really get an
credit for it as individuals
If you go to the CIA,
for example, or you go --
you'll see stars on the wall
with no names.
These are people who serve our
country and die for our countr
who never get
personal acknowledgement.
And, you know, and honestly, I
think that it's really important
at this moment
to also credit them
knowing that you've had Donald
Trump as the Commander-In-Chief,
who has spent full time
attacking the integrity
and the professionalism
and the sacrifice of
those professionals.
So I think about it in tha
regard and thank them
for their service
and for their dedication
and for being, you know, smart
and with great sacrifice
doing the work they're doing t
protect our national security.
Donald Trump.
That press conference
was extraordinary.
You would've think that
he was talking about
watching and giving commentary
on a video game.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
-He is the Commander-In-Chief.
The Commander-In-Chief of
the United States of America
has as her highest priorit
the responsibility
to concern herself...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...with our nation's securit
and the security of
our homeland.
And I just -- at every step,
becomes clear that I just --
he clearly does not fully
appreciate the importance
of the job, which must be done
with integrity,
must be done in a way
that is solemn,
understanding what is at stake
But I give full credit to ou
military, to our special forces,
to our intelligence committe
for the work they've done
and continue to do.
-You are a former --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Absolutely.
You are a former prosecutor.
Obviously there -- you know,
it seems like the House
is not gonna vote on
this impeachment inquiry
officially this week.
-Yeah.
-As a prosecutor,
do you look at the evidenc
against Donald Trump,
the impeachment evidence -
are there times that you say
this is almost
too much evidence?
Do you think that --
[ Laughter ]
Well, because it does
seem as though,
and we don't officially
know yet,
there might be sort of
a narrow focus in the House of
"let's just focus on Ukraine
and what happened with
that quid pro quo,"
as opposed to the fact that yo
could really kind of
just pick any country...
[ Laughter ]
-China.
-...and say, what are
the illegal things
that happened there?
Do you think that's
the right way to move forward?
And do you think there's enoug
evidence for a quid pro qu
with what we've seen and heard
so far with Ukraine?
-I do.
It's extraordinary
to your point.
We have a clear display of
consciousness of guilt,
when they were attempting
to then put the transcript
in some secret computer.
We have a cover-up.
That is that.
And we have a confession.
And as a former prosecutor,
know a confession when I see it.
And the fact that Donald Trump
does what he does
in plain sight,
maybe he thinks it should
in some way absolve him.
You know, I remember, there was,
I think it was Richard Pryor -
who was it who had a skit
and he would say,
"Don't believe your lying eyes,"
right?
Oh, it was fantastic.
-I don't know,
but I'm excited to Google it
-It was when he got caught
cheating on his wife.
-Oh, gotcha.
-And he would say to his wife,
"Don't believe your lying eyes."
Right?
The American public,
we know what we see.
And frankly, somebody ought to
tell Donald Trump
he has a right to remain silent.
-Now, let me ask you this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
For the right to remain silent
And again, I'm a layperson here.
You are someone who enjoys -
I shouldn't say enjoys.
You are someone
who understands the law.
You are a former prosecutor.
Rudy Giuliani
is a former prosecutor.
To my -- a layperson's eyes --
-Yeah.
-He doesn't look like he's goo
at this anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Now, I might be wrong.
Could you tell me right now,
"Seth, you misunderstand.
He's so good.
This is the sneaky --
It's a gambit, Seth.
And you're falling --"
He's not good, right?
-No, he's not good.
-Yeah.
-And it's such --
and this is the thing about --
I don't know
if it's the Trump touch,
but it literally --
the disintegration
that we have seen of the offic
of the President
of the United States,
of people who serve in
the highest roles
in terms of being
in the Cabinet,
chiefs of staff
or secretaries of communication,
the disintegration we've see
of those offices including
the disintegration of somebody
who is a well-regarded mayor
of New York during one of
the most challenging times
in our nation's history,
it's extraordinary to watch.
And it's sad.
It frankly is very sad.
-Well, it is going
to be exciting
to watch this field of peopl
move forward.
-Yes.
-We're happy to have you in it
-Thank you.
-And we're so happy
you made time for us again
-Thank you.
It's great to be here.
-Give it up one more time
for Senator Kamala Harris.